my name is Denise Russo and I'm 32 years
old I'm from Queens New York New York
girls are crazy and we say how it is you
know I don't like and I'm not going to
change because I live in California
Denise Russo known from VH1's the
ex-life has died she was 44 years old
[Music]
TMZ reports that law enforcement found
Denise unresponsive Sunday on the floor
of a friend's home in San Diego the
outlet reports that First Responders
arrived and attempted to resuscitate her
but she was eventually pronounced dead
ET has reached out to San Diego Police
for confirmation according to TMZ drug
paraphernalia was found at the scene the
cause of death is still pending and San
Diego PD is currently investigating
state
G or Pierre Lu Kenyon he is a
professional Bert skater the 2011
reality series followed the lives of
extreme sports athletes and their
Partners what I love about Pierre is
that he is very loyal to me and when
there's someone that's attacking me you
know appears right there backing me up
Denise definitely has a strong attitude
and this is definitely the thing I love
about her because you know she's not one
of those girls that you know does
everything you tell her and you know she
answers back to you and I don't know I
just you know like a girl that has
attitude Denise was dating professional
skateboarder Pierre Luke Gagnon at the
time they had a son together but have
since broken up I want to make a toast
host friends and to the women at the
table for dealing with these crazy boys
Susie Stenberg Denise's friend and
former the ex-life castmate told TMZ
Denise was homeless and living in her
car when she died
ET has reached out to Susie for comment
following the sad news Susie shared this
image to her Instagram story writing
that Denise was more loyal than most
adding quote I'll miss you sweet friend
R.I.P
foreign